when it comes down to strategy sessions
there's two different kinds of strategy
sessions one of them is just on the cup
we go into board and we grab a marker we
start writing we say what we're going to
do next that could be on a day to day
basis weekly basis the kind of strategy
session I want to talk about here is the
one I do once every year and I've been
doing this as 2005 2006 where you go
away with certain group of people with a
specific outcome on what to do for the
following year you know so many people
want to wing themselves into an
incredible year and all of a sudden my
gosh this thing is gonna start working
out for me and it doesn't the reason why
I'm sharing this with you is because
you're talking to a master winger i
stewing everything about my business
until 2005 2006 I decided every single
year during December I'm gonna get away
and I called it mastermind Alliance this
is a strategy session a retreat where we
get together with our core leaders this
becomes my entire emphasis of leadership
development casting my next innovative
campaign you notic the entire team to
get again a good kind of a pulse on
where everybody is that I get to look at
their eyeballs together and then if we
unite you feel one of unite if we unite
I already know we're gonna start the
next year on a strong strong momentum
simply because we had that strategy
session to get in the month of December
so now if you're watching this impact I
don't want to do it in December I want
to do in September July January February
whatever season it is you're watching
and no matter what it is you can kick it
up on any month I'm just telling you I
did it in December in this video I'm
gonna share with you the twelve things
that I did every single year going into
these strategy sessions number one so
the first thing you got to keep on -
this is not a meaning to invite
everybody because we're gonna get
together we're gonna have fun sucker
shindig oh my gosh we're gonna do all
this other great things together this is
a very serious meaning for me with a
sprinkle of fun because everybody needs
to have a little bit of fun for their
mind to be opened up so they're willing
to take things from you but I don't
invite everybody the people that get
invited to this meaning are leaders
I even announced what needs to be taking
place way in advance as a criteria for
folks to want to be part of this meaning
this allows me to realize who really
wants to be there by doubling down on
their effort what happens when you do
this is those who double
their efforts to be there are coming
there with a specific outcome of
bringing value to the meeting and those
who you invite to don't take it for what
it's worth the value of it they kind of
come in entitled feeling like oh my gosh
you know he has to me you like pulling
ideas out of them I like to have some
kind of a fight of people wanting to get
into the strategy session especially the
ones that I do once a year number two so
here's the next thing that I do
everybody that comes you have an
assignment here's what the assignment
could be one of the assignments is a
book you got to reach I need you to read
this book write a paper on it send it to
me before this meeting in order to for
you to get into this meaning and
literally we get papers or if you don't
bring the paper and type that not
written out type that three paragraphs
that's your ticket you won't be able to
get in